David I loved the Artful Dodger the
first few se episodes of the Season that
we saw were excellent thank you um I
studied Dickens fairly extensively at
Uni and you know his his stories have
become the backbone of a lot of modern
storytelling specifically with um
historical dramas I'm curious what was
your first introduction to Charles
Dickens um it was it's all of a Twist um
really we I'm of an age where when when
the musical first came out um
um I was a young boy and it was it was
ubiquitous it was all all over the place
we knew all the songs we used to do the
songs at school later in life I actually
became friends with Lionel Bart who
wrote it um uh was a very very beautiful
beautiful man um so through that and I I
think through television drama and films
first of all before I I I came across
the books much later I I never studied
them at school they wasn't on our
curriculum so I didn't even come across
them actually until I started working as
an actor one of my first jobs was in
little doret uh and that's the first
time I ever I ever read Dickens and then
I think in my own time I obviously David
CFI Great Expectations Oliver Twist
which I of course uh read read again for
this and your portrayal of Fagan is
excellent what was your like character
work for building him and flushing him
out like well I it's it was all I felt
like it was all there even in my first
reading of of of the scpt uh which you
know I was so impressed with I read it
on an airplane and and by the time I
landed I just rang my agent said I'm
doing this CU it was so wonderfully
written straight away and I thought it
was beautifully funny uh and and and a
different take a more sympathetic Fagan
certainly than the the than the novel
and and rarely than any any of the other
uh films uh you know which I went back
and and watched most things uh I wasn't
sure if that was a good idea or not but
I did go back to to make sure I wasn't
repeating anything or to see where
people might have gone wrong uh in
earlier portrayals but um you know James
and Andrew uh their writing is so
complete by time you come to the come to
the script it's it's all it's all done
for you just really it was a matter of
just learning it and uh I I didn't feel
like I had to really bring a lot of
interpretation to it other than what was
already there you've had a run of
playing villainous characters here in
the last few years and I love that Fagan
kind of toes this line of moral
ambiguity in a lot of ways because you
know he's he's a con man um what is more
fun kind of diving into a more
villainous kind of character or playing
with this very Shades of Gray for Fagan
i i i the latter I think because you
know in fact he's not the villain in in
this in this show you know um we have
two we have gains and cracks with you
know Damon Herman and Tim men you know
are the bad guys I'm I'm more of a kind
of a rascal um you know and I and I
think that was that was more enjoyable
for me there's more humor in it which I
which I I love I don't get to do as much
comedy as I would like and I thought he
was beautifully funny in the scripts um
and yeah he's certainly a more
sympathetic uh as as he's written in
his relationship with with dodger but
there is still the obviously the
underlying criminality of of his
thievery but there is also some steal to
him and you know and and some cruelty to
him physical cruelty is is prepared to
go to um in some scenes um but it was
much more interesting for me than just
playing some mustache twirling you know
just he's a bad guy with no other
dimensions to him which sometimes is is
what I i' I've been offered and done and
they're good as well they're always fun
always more fun than playing good guys I
find but uh this this was nice cuz he's
he's a bad guy but he's kind of lovable
one of the things I think is really
interesting is we get this really great
relationship between him and Jack um
what was it like kind of playing with
something that's been established you
know very prolifically established in
the book and people know what to kind of
expect coming into it and then getting
to really flesh it out and explore
different Avenues and almost see a
gentler side of Fagan with Jack because
he does seem like he genuinely cares
about um
yeah I think there's a I think there's a
great love there and that that was going
back to the idea of the characterization
I think that is something I I did want
to bring to it myself I I I I often when
I do things almost always just keep one
piece of information secret to myself I
know don't discuss with the directors or
the other actors or the writers and and
and and that for this was his his actual
deep deep love for essentially his
surrogate son and that most things he
does in the course of these stories is
is is aim toward towards that that's the
real treasure that's actually why he's
here to to try and save this
relationship um and of course it's all
uh there to be developed because we're
seeing certainly in the case of Jack a a
a figure who is much more evolved than
the last time we saw him in the books or
in the movies uh where he's become
something surprisingly sophisticated of
course you know which is the whole Twist
of the um the story line he's now a
surgeon he's he's is rather educated in
his own way he he he speaks beautifully
he's he's been a naval officer um and
he's he's he's he's quite brilliant and
he's rather attractive young man and
he's you know so he's very different to
the the young boy we met and I think
that's what's going to uh interest
people is is is is making that leap that
Thomas does so beautifully from what you
might expect the little boy to grow up
to be and what actually this young man
that we see here I completely agree I
think that was one of the most
surprising aspects of you know the
series um you know I think a question
that actors get a lot is like what part
of yourself do you bring to a character
but I'm curious what part of Fagan kind
of like stuck with you after you
wrapped well my beard for a a long time
I've never grown such long beard on my
my my my bald bald head um I I it was it
was rather difficult to let them both go
uh I I loved having a shaved head and I
loved having that beard and the day I
had to cut it off when I back to England
it was it was rather emotional cuz I'd
lived with it for so so long it been
such my wife was very relieved um it was
it was uh something I I'd enjoyed
playing the role so much and enjoyed
kind of looking like that so much such a
I felt like a different personality as
myself so so just the the physicality of
of Fagan I I I miss and you know hoping
if we do another season quite looking
forward to looking like that again yeah
that I mean perfectly ties into the next
question I had which you know we've only
seen the first half of this season do
you think there is room to continue to
tell this story and this is just a
Beautiful Beginning undoubtedly
undoubtedly because and I say that
because I know most people have like
yourself have only seen four episodes
and what I can say hand on heart with
with with this it gets better and better
and better even more than I realized
when I watched it I was like my God this
is getting this is getting really really
good now and I think the by time you're
into the final three episodes the final
two final one it's something that you
it's becomes a whole different project
it becomes something that really takes
you by surprise and is is is is so
moving and it it it becomes more
political becomes more
philosophical um in a way that I didn't
even realize when I read the scripts uh
which is a lot to do with the
performances of of of of Thomas and and
mea towards the end and and Susie
reporter indeed um so I think there's no
doubt by the time you see episode 8 that
you're like oh yeah there's definitely
definitely more places this could go and
because the writers are so fantastic I
think they're just chomping at the bit
to to to give us more well that has me
very excited for where things could go
and you know one of the aspects I really
loved about it is how beautiful it is
the scenery is gorgeous what was it like
to film in Australia uh well just
wonderful I I I I just adore it here I
feel like it's now my my second home I
just I just feel great Affinity with
this with this city with these people um
you know my favorite day on it was the
where we shot the Dual scene by the
ocean CU we were often in in kind of
quite claustrophobic Victorian sets and
we got to shoot one day on The Cliffs by
the ocean near botony Bay and I just
remember that day most of the cast were
there and I was just thinking how lucky
lucky lucky I am to to have a job where
this is a the day's work to um to to be
in this country in this scenery with
beautiful people making this kind of
wonderful show Beyond like you know the
last three episodes which seemed to be
really exciting are there any particular
episodes that really stuck out for the
work that you got to do and bring
bringing Fagan's story to like life in
that episode well I I I think as as it
goes on like I say I think I think
episode six uh there's there's there's
there's stuff in that where it really I
feel like the character the relationship
between uh Fagan and Dodger really grew
and and we get a little more backstory
and it gets a little more serious um in
some ways the the comedy uh takes a
backseat sometimes and and there's there
there's a wonderful speech that James
wrote for me in episode 6 that suddenly
I felt like I was doing something much
more uh
substantial um so I I like I say as as
it as it goes on it's beautifully nutty
all the way through but I think it it it
turns it turn turns a corer later on and
um and and I I really liked that and
that's why I'd love to be more of it cuz
I feel like now we've we've we've
already done that that we have to keep
doing that and keep bringing some
gravitas to it as well as all the kind
of high Jinks this might be a spoilery
question but it's like my you know
loving Dickens wanting to know like what
else to expect are there any other
Dickens characters from oliv twist that
show up either in flashbacks or like cuz
I feel like there's so many other
characters out there that we you know
were left with uncertain Fates at the
end of all twist that could easily show
up to cause trouble uh perhaps you'll
have to see I I I know actually there
was an idea to to to to bring in
characters even from other books if
that's what I talk earlier on when if in
a second season but you know so where
therefore there might be you know Mr M
might which which characters from other
books did come out to here to here to
Australia so um I I know I know that
would be great fun to do but um we we we
we won't be able to tell you exactly
what the plans are as we wind down on
this interview I I'm curious to know
what do you hope that audiences take
away from the series um I hope they
um see a whole new way of presenting the
world the world of of Dickens because
it's never been done out here in in in
in this country and just to uh you know
enjoy all the possibilities that that
brings to to to take everything we love
about Dickens in England transpose it to
this beautiful land and uh and see all
the opportunities that U you know that
that are exploited so so wonderfully
again credit to the writers um because
they've done a fantastic job and I'm I'm
very impressed excellent well thank you
so much David the series truly was
excellent and I agree seeing Dickens
through this light is just extremely
exciting thank you thank you take care
excellent